yes I'm on the line yes yeah okay hello
Jennifer
Maurice yeah sir this question is
actually directed towards Maurice
Maurice I get calls about maybe eight
months ago and we spoke about
development of chess in Africa and then
you know Nakamura was kind enough to
sponsor the two chess players to Italy
to play a few tournaments so I was
wondering if you can give an update
normally on those two players but on
general how the the improvement of chess
and ethical factoring well thanks for
that question and yes Nakamura did visit
South Africa and boy to a great fanfare
as he played blitz in the park there I
believe it was in Johannesburg and the
fans just loved it and they have such a
world-class player being able to visit
that place and and just light up the
chest stratosphere was amazing you did
sponsor two players
I don't recall how they did in the
tournament so I do not have an update
there I can check for you but as far as
the development of chess in Africa you
know continue slowly but there was one
big event huge event that was recently
executed and with the help of Graham
Jorgensen of the castara of chess
Foundation Africa it was done in Abidjan
in on the Ivory Coast or in the Ivory
Coast the country of the Ivory Coast
Cote d'Ivoire as they say there and they
brought talent from all over Africa top
players from countries all over to play
and it was the commentary was done from
here as well it's a really special event
I think you can get it on YouTube and
again just baby steps but I think that
one was a big one it was modeled off the
st. Louis rapid and blitz or the
Grantchester rapid and blitz events it
was very exciting
so you can take a look at that and I
think that all the players are feeling
like they want to make that an annual
event and more events like that should
be able to promote chess on the African
continent
so that was like the African all-star
yes all the top ten in the whole
continent of Africa coming together for
rapid and blitz